alors je le dis c'est mon conseil de
classe et bon d'appréciation up
bonjour mis sur ton année puisqu'on est
à deux jours de la fin de l'année ses
missions jean-mi je te le dis tu as fait
une année exceptionnelle chaque année je
dis que c'est ta meilleure amie
et je vous dis vas pas aller plus loin
et arrive à aller plus haut tu es le
tina arena dès mi temps mais vraiment
forme et s'enrhumait à chaque fois tu
arrives aller plus haut tu a gommé parce
que je dit aux téléspectateurs
je vais demander de gommer un petit peu
le côté un petit peu trash
voilà parce que bon il a fait pareil et
la côte est un peu voilà un peu voilà
parfois l'audace halal ou non mais non
pas du tout et moi de là tout comme et
il n'a gardé que le meilleur or alors
mais à ceux venant des quelques fois à
côté mais c'est très rare
franchement tu es le mba paix de thé
paiement et sa grande force c'est qu'un
homme de goût avec un grand sens de
l'analyse regarde même pas benhaim
deuxième panneau je vous alors moi je
vous adore chez à lahonce un milieu je
trouve que vous avez déjà monter encore
un peu plus haut la barre on est en
terme d'animation je pousse et c'est ouf
personne ne fait ça c'est pas une info
que je donne ça fait c'est que vous êtes
le génie le mozart du paf ça c'est pas
moi qui lis les audiences fait ni à
chaque fois moi je vous dis est-ce que
j'ai pas un trésor dans ma maison
donc c'est vous le traitez vous trésor
d'être d'état seigneur d'arras d'essayer
je trouve à nous est de la race des
loges au niveau des chefs de bourg n'est
pas mal là aujourd'hui je ne mettrai pas
de notes je m'alignerai d'appréciation
le syndicat fait une année
exceptionnelle ça me touche est fière de
toi je sais que tu seras avec nous pour
la 10ème bien sûr ça bah oui on sait
c'est quand même pas on se pose même pas
la question tu feras je le dis bien et
je le dis ce soir
première info il fera toutes les
émissions avec moi mais non jean-michel
du début à la fin
c'est jeudi le seul ici donc il fera
toutes les émissions avec moi en sait
vraiment voilà c'est cholet mais il le
sait jean-michel objets anciens et tu
sais que je t'aime mon agent me tue a
été encore exceptionnel bravo
aujourd'hui isabelle ma chérie à autre
chose qu isabelle on appelle tes cheveux
en fait c'est isabelle c'est la deuxième
plus ancienne dans la bande voilà et il
n'a que c'est toi aussi je peux pas me
passer de toi tu te fais partie vraiment
des pilotis de cette émission
non mais vraiment alors je te le dis
c'est vrai que tu dis jamais du mal de
m6 mais tu commences tu commences à en
dire je trouve que tu es en train de te
lâcher c'est vrai que tu parle souvent
plus en dehors de l'émission que dans
l'émission mais ça nous fait qui fait
aussi et même si tu racontes toujours
les mêmes d'anecdotes est bon les kiffe
toujours plus à chaque fois tu peux
continuer il a bien sûr tu seras avec
moi en saison 10 isa je le dis et
franchement c'est une fusion c'est une
jeune femme assise à ne se réveille tous
les jours à 3h du matin qui est là tous
les soirs
t'as jamais manqué l'émission qui dit
jamais non pour un happening qui dit
jamais non pour ceux déguisés qui à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des trucs voilà
où il ya eu des trucs qui voient là le
chocolat tout ça elle était toujours là
elle a jamais rien dit franchement voilà
il a vraiment je te le dis tu as encore
fait une année exceptionnelle et je le
vois les gens t'aiment
et moi aussi je t'aime fort et j'espère
que tu seras avec moi sur la dixième
année est vraiment donc lâchera jamais
comme tu le sais tu es fait partie de la
famille et toi aussi là tu feras de très
très nombreuses émissions avec moi je
crois pratiquement toute l'année
prochaine tu en feras ton fera à peu
près voilà tu m'entends manquera une par
semaine seulement
mais tu seras là tout le temps avec
et en plus ça on a un point commun tous
les deux puisque à lens ouais on est
balancé en plus on a le même syndrome a
tendance insulte un petit coup de canon
de batam matthieu delormeau au bord des
lacs eux elle est devenue on va faire de
dispute avec ma mère pourquoi elle aime
pas quand vous parlez malgré elle guette
tous les maux chrome os jeudi et après
j'en ai pour trois semaines
non on embrasse savoir comment il
s'appelle paul on le voit c'est bravo
pour les boulangeries non c'est vrai
certes les boulangeries sartec non
vraiment vous certes les boulangeries
doc gynéco à doc gynéco alors je vous le
dis et je dis la vérité
quand j'ai dit à la production on va
prendre doc gynéco dompter pmp quand
j'ai dit aux autres chroniqueurs on va
prendre d'objets déco dans tpm p tout le
monde a dit isabelle tu étais - mais non
un témoin a dit on le on y croit pas du
tout à doc dans tpm p est ce qu'il va
pouvoir venir tous les jours
est ce qu'il y ait là est-ce qu'il va
s'intégrer à l'équipe voilà et j'étais
sûr vraiment mon cou parce que doc il à
ce que vous avez tous pour moi ici c'est
le point commun bouteille c'est qu'il a
un coeur énorme
c'est un amour de making alors même si
c'est valable aussi pour vous même si
vous êtes à bâtir de leurs maux vous
avez vous à moi mon coeur non mais c'est
vrai et docks
il a un coeur énorme et surtout il est
très intelligent donc il sait exactement
voilà ce qu'on attend de lui dans
l'émission kampeter
il sait qu'en se taire il sait qu'en
parler il s'est surtout quand se taire
en plus il m'a dit moi y était venu voir
à l'époque il m'a dit voilà cyrine moi
je cherche un endroit pour faire la
sieste entre 19 états unis j'ai
peut-être un endroit voilà c'est vrai
que quand ils se réveillent qu'il a des
fulgurances incroyable ça a été je le
dis la plus belle recrue a depuis ses
cinq gamins fans
là il a tout de suite intégré l'équipe
maintenant je n'imagine pas une
manipulation sans doc avait et j'ai
oublié en fait aussi assez que l'année
prochaine je les fera aussi pratiquement
tout avec moi donc tu feras vraiment
partie de l'équipe même avec des
émissions vous verrez qu'il y aura des
petites choses en plus et ben il sera là
et docks tu seras toujours avec moi et
je te le dis tu es formidable mais alors
j'ai pas de fiche mais je crois qu'on a
un petit truc tu rien certes on n'a rien
sur toi c désignant pour les tôles à
médoc dodji mais ils sont dix neuf ans
quand on s'en fout pendant qu'on est
apte à passer les banques tu es content
ouais tu vas revenir l'année prochaine
fois que je vois jamais demandé non mais
c'est on peut pas on aurait du mal
vraiment refuser
c'est quelque chose quoi pour l'argent
non plus pas pour savoir ce que je te
connais tu sais que maintenant on sait
que je ne sais pas
on est là plus pour s'amuser pour la
bonne entente et moi aussi de mon côté
j'ai je pensais pas y arriver parce que
je me suis dit que peut-être à les
intégrer peut-être quelque chose où il y
avait des difficultés parce que je suis
quelqu'un de calme
reda c'est poser c'est difficile pour
moi de dire parfois dé tenir des propos
sur des sujets de prendre de donner ton
avis de prendre position pour prendre
wikio sia du mal à prendre position
j'aime pas à merci et donc j'ai besoin
de tarbes où tous les ballons aussi
beaucoup parce que tu sais tu connais ma
pudeur alors tim vous permet aussi de
des fois tu me rattrape qui m'empêche de
dire des choses que je supporterai pas
je vais mal dormir après un salut toi
[Applaudissements]
tu fais toi on va quoi moi c'est
l'inversé d'une gentillesse de repas
ouais donc vraiment j'ai tout sera
derrière nous à des projets et je trouve
que tu as fait une année
[Applaudissements]